[Music]
now things have cooled off a little bit
here in Los Angeles I mean Monday you
remember Monday it was like 120 degrees
here thanks for that ooh
but ladies and gentlemen it continues
most of the Southwest is still in the
grips of a major heat wave now naturally
my writers have been coming up with a
lot of heat related jokes all week all
right
way too many for me to be able to do all
of them they just come up with too many
I didn't want them to go to waste
okay I've paid good money for these
jokes so I thought it was a perfect
opportunity to introduce the latest in
rapid fire heat joke-telling
technology it's called the heat bot 3000
a robot that only tells heat related
jokes let's get heat
[Applause]
okay hey there he bought how you doing
I'm hot it is hot out it is so hot
IceCube changed his name to puddle sink
it is so hot earlier this week on The
Bachelorette
Jojo gave a rose to a snowman ooh okay
so hot Donald Trump is just full of
room-temperature air oh okay it's so hot
Bill Clinton slept with Hillary just a
cool little rough work and topical there
it's so hot my car's truck nuts are
touching the road oh it is so hot in
Phoenix that all of the petting zoos are
now KFC
that's funny thank you very much bye
again so hot I put in a DVD of frozen
and it played Waterworld oh and it's so
hot I begged RuPaul to throw me some
shade that's finding it so hot Kanye
West stepped out of the spotlight can I
get an amen
okay Nick with hurt or not paid by we've
heard enough
do you like impressions oh we don't want
to try this Seth Rogen as a microwave
oven beep beep I'm really high that's
not an impression
now now have you ever noticed white
robots walk like this what are you doing
okay black robots walk like this okay
that's no yo yo you just said yo yo yo
that's all you did
I'm not even heat-related that joke I
will do my dirty stuff no don't do dirty
stuff we don't want to hear dirty stuff
[Applause]
Thank You robot ladies you gotta take
care of yourself down there robot ladies
if you wash your bolts I'll wash my nuts
Andy knows what I'm talking about right
Andy I bet his nuts are filthy yeah we
have an amazing show tonight star of the
new movie Independence Day resurgence
Liam Hemsworth is here
[Applause]
to me what I would check now just this
do no no no no you're into that
well I'm very open mind okay from the
Netflix original series orange is the
new black I would love to [ __ ] servos
with her that's fine yeah and here's a
guess
Twin Peaks here that is my nickname for
Sofia Vergara that's talking about her
boobs I hate you I will take a breath
right back take it away
you